hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number is it 141
142. it's 142. which was literally the
last thing i said to you before we came
on air really yeah okay here's the thing
i do listen to you intently for all
kinds of reasons and then there's
moments before the podcast and things
like that and yes my mind is doing that
the buffer was full for sure the buffer
thank you for rationalizing on my behalf
i appreciate that
so it's good stuff
hello everyone here we are here we are
here we are in this uh in this makeshift
setup
uh where for those of you just listening
we've been here before
uh it is uh it's a bit kludgy it's gonna
remain a bit clutchy for a while we're
still waiting on the fiber optic for our
new studio to get uh to burrow
underneath a bunch of stuff and to to
get to
to the place so it's gonna be a few
weeks of of cluj
but uh hopefully few weeks include
before we get to the
next level yeah next level clutch yeah
that's what we're shooting for
all right
so um
we got some business
for so today we're going to be talking
about uh the chilean constitution a
little bit and uh affirmative action for
women in stem
and myopia
europia i consider it all of our opinion
increasingly
really wow
i tried it it wasn't great it makes no
sense at all it was inexpensive
for you
fair point
okay and here we have our epic tabby
joining us fairfax is here we got
madison snoring off street of of uh
off-screen here maddie all right name
for james even though she's a girl
yes
and
okay business
business i should i was gonna clap i
shoot everyone out of their seats no you
don't clapping yeah
okay uh we follow these live streams
with the q a we haven't for a couple of
weeks but uh we're gonna do that today
unless unless tech problems get in the
way please ask your questions you can
start asking questions now they've been
formulating their questions for weeks
for weeks at
darkhorsesubmissions.com we don't get to
all of them but we get to as many as we
can
uh this is the this week is the one year
anniversary of the publication of a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century our
new york times best-selling book uh that
approaches all of many of the issues of
modern life with an evolutionary lens
and points to the problem of hyper
novelty as causing many of our problems
and this actually
will come full circle and talk about
that when we talk about myopia to finish
up the show quite by accident but it
shows up at just the right moment for
the anniversary right but i mean the
fact is
that every week there's some story that
is relevant to the question of oh my god
what are we doing to ourselves how
should we be living now and frankly that
is precisely the set of prescriptions uh
and ways of thinking that we
that we
produce and propose in a hundred
gatherers guide to the 21st century so
if you haven't read it consider picking
up a copy or finding it at your local
library there are many copies of our new
local library i was pleased to discover
which is marvelous yes um and it's also
available in many other languages so
including spanish and french and soon to
be many many others
and my computer is set to go to sleep
too quickly
if you're watching on youtube consider
switching to odyssey that's where the
chat is live
we have a store of course
darkhorsestore.org
where we've got the shirts that we
introduced last week keep portland weird
all caps western educated industrialized
rich and democratic
and a lot of other stuff as well
consider joining me on natural
selections at
naturalselections.substance.com
and finally with regard to
housekeeping business we are supported
by our audience we appreciate you
subscribing to
uh the channel that you're watching on
be at youtube or odyssey or uh if you're
if you're listening on you know spotify
or apple podcasts
uh liking the videos uh go if you're
finding this through the clips channel
that's awesome although you probably
aren't finding this to the clips channel
sharing whatever you find and like both
are full episodes and also the clips
dark horse podcast clips again on either
odyssey or youtube and
youtube as has now been noticed by many
has begun uh increasingly ads that it
puts on our videos even though it fully
demonetized us about 14 months ago now
with the rationalization that it wasn't
appropriate for advertisers right right
so they're making money on us but we're
not making money on us at least not
through youtube
so that's that's fun uh we do have
patreons you can join uh either or both
of ours on either of them you get access
to our discord community where
honest conversations on difficult topics
take place all the time they're they
have karaoke night they have virtual
happy hours they're doing an actual uh
real-life meetup uh camping uh shortly
like
within days of now uh there are some um
book clubs
lovely things that happen on the discord
community and right now on my patreon
you can ask questions that we will be
answering in next week's private q a we
do a private q a for people on my
patreon at the on the last sunday of
every month and brett has
some more intimate conversations on his
patreon including one that you had just
this morning one that we had just this
morning it was a very active
conversation we are talking about what
it is that might be done to protect uh
the united states and the world from the
catastrophe of our upcoming
midterm elections and in any case that
conversation is likely to make its way
to a upcoming
dark horse live stream we're going to
discuss some of the things that we have
come up with all right so uh anyway it's
it's um
obviously an important moment and and
the coalition of the reasonable is
motivated great
wonderful
uh and of course
uh we have sponsors uh all all of our
sponsors uh produce products or services
that we actually and truly vouch for we
have three each week at the top of the
show you'll always know if we are
reading um
reading material for which we are paid
by the
little sound before and after
the ads and the green perimeter on the
screen if you are watching
but again you don't read ads for
products or services that we don't
actually stand for stand by
without further ado
all right our first sponsor this week is
new to us this summer we're excited to
be partnering with them it is thesis
thesis makes no tropics the tropics are
nutrients found in nature or in the
human body that have been demonstrated
to enhance mental performance in areas
such as motivation creativity mood
memory focus and cognitive processing
they work best when combined with
exercise proper nutrition and
mindfulness activity such as meditation
and you're probably already using
anatropic as one of the most commonly
consumed ones is caffeine but it's far
from the most exciting
effective nootropics allow people to
optimize their focus energy and mood
based on the demands of the day in some
cases no tropics can replace the
pharmaceuticals that are usually used to
tackle a problem such as adhd
thesis is unusual in the nootropic
market and taking a very personalized
approach they do not assume that what
works for your brother will work for you
whether what worked for you when you
were under deadline for a joyful project
will be the same as what will work for
you when you need a spark of creativity
for a project you've been dreaming of
for years for instance just as some
people become alert after a cup of
coffee and others can fall right asleep
so too do all nootropics have different
effects on different people
with the first iteration of thesis
products customers who did not know what
blend they were taking took a series of
different notrepic blends over the
course of a month and reported how they
felt they were effectively being treated
as subjects in a clinical trial analysis
of their feedback found that not
surprisingly different people respond
differently to different blends now
after two years 2 500 customers and
millions of data points thesis is
confident that they have created a
recommendation algorithm to predict
which blends of no tropics will work
best for any given customer
the process is simple go to their
website take a short quiz and they'll
send a starter kit with four different
blend recommendations to try over the
course of a month
i've tried several blends now and a few
of them haven't been my thing but three
have been intriguing and i've returned
to them the creativity blend for
instance seems to smooth things over and
add a little clarity make inspiration
come a bit easier and the logic blend
seems to facilitate focus and getting
lots of tasks done with fully
personalizable blends there is likely to
be a thesis that's right for you
to get your own customized thesis
starter kit go online to take thesis.com
darkhorse take the quiz and use code
dark course at checkout for 10 off your
first box
our second awesome sponsor this week is
moich that's moo plus oink m-o-i-n-k
an eighth generation farmer founded moic
and is working hard to help save the
family farm and get its customers access
to the highest quality meat on earth did
you know that 97 of the chickens served
in the u.s are dipped in chlorine well
family farms don't tend to do that and
certainly the meat you get from wink
doesn't
moic delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and wild caught alaskan
salmon direct to your door
moik farmers farm like our grandparents
did and as a result moink meat tastes
like it should which is to say delicious
unlike the supermarket what gives you
total control of the quality and source
of your food you choose the meat
delivered in every box like rib eyes
chicken breasts to pork chops to salmon
fillets and much more plus you can
cancel any time we love everything about
moik the fact that the meat is grass-fed
and finished on small farms the lovely
publications that come along with it and
of course the meat itself
shark tank host kevin o'leary called
monk's bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted i agree it's amazing
keep american farming going by signing
up at moinkbox.com
darkhorse right now and listeners of
this show will receive free filet mignon
for a year that's one year of the best
filet mignon you'll ever taste but for a
limited time
spelled m-o-i-n-k-b-o-x
dot com slash dark horse that's
moiquebox.com
horse
all right our final wonderful sponsor
this week is vevo barefoot these are
shoes made by people with feet for
people with feet
uh are we sure
i have not checked what is in their
shoes but we've uh you know
gathered with them and i
i've never seen i've never seen the
bottom you are challenging the veracity
of their claim to have feet
did they claim to have feet no i'm
claiming they have feedback yeah so it's
your client i'm challenging the veracity
of your claim that they have feet fair
enough
nonetheless i think the listeners should
try these shoes we love these shoes yes
whether or not the makers of them have
feet
irrespective of how they came to be
there we have feet and we have tried
these shoes and they work wonderfully
they're beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from the surfaces you're
walking on is amazing they cause no pain
at all because there are no pressure
points forcing your feet into odd
positions
they are
fantastic our feet are the product of
millions of years of evolution humans
evolved to walk move and run barefoot
but modern shoes that are overly
cushioned and strangely shaped have
negatively impacted foot function and
are contributing to a health crisis one
in which people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet heart hurt
vivobarefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by 60
in a matter of months just by walking
around in them the number of people
wearing vivo barefoots is growing once
people start wearing these shoes they
don't seem to stop i had two people just
this week stop and comment on my
vivobarefoot's both wearers of the shoes
in fact i heard from what may be one of
them who
emailed me to say i finally ran into
brett which i've been wanting to do
and i was pretty sure it was him but
then i looked at the footwear and i was
sure he was sure well there you go so if
you want to be mistaken for me which you
probably don't but if you do
now you know one way to get there
vivobarefoot has a great range of
footwear for kids and adults
and for every activity from hiking to
training to everyday wear they are
certified b corp pioneering regenerative
business principles and their footwear
is produced using sustainably sourced
naturally natural and recycled materials
with the aim to protect the natural
world so you can run wild on it go to
vivobarefoot.com
darkhorse to get an exclusive offer 20
off additionally all new customers get a
100 day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do
that's vevobarefoot.com v-i-v-o-b-a-r
dot com slash dark horse
all right
well because we are a bit clued you
today i can't share my screen with you
so i'm i'm going to apologize in advance
for
a few a few gaps in what i'm doing uh
the first thing we want to talk about
today is
the constitution
in chile that was just put before a vote
that would have been a replacement of
the constitution
of over of about 40 years that's been in
place since pinochet's time
and it was uh it was widely discussed in
the media
including in nature as a pro-science
constitution
so let me
and so at the point that it was voted
down by i think a 62-38
vote 62 60 of the voting public in chile
said no to this
uh it would appear that chile is
anti-science they're backwards they're
like agrarian in the 19th century and
they really aren't interested in in
moving forward with the times and and
embracing science and nature reports for
instance
that
oh boy
and i
have lost my safari here to show you
guys
that
in september 7th 2022 nature again one
of the top two science journals in the
world in its news section
has a headline i feel lost which is a
quote from a researcher chilean
researchers saddened by vote to reject
new constitution
nearly 62 percent of chileans voted
against the proposed charter which would
have boosted science that's the headline
and when you go into the
into the actual article
you find
the votes are in and many scientists are
disappointed on the 4th of september
chileans voted to reject a proposed new
constitution for their nation the draft
charter developed over a year by a
citizen-led assembly framed science as a
tool that could improve society
it also emphasized actions against
climate change and support for research
across all of chile rather than only
institutions in the capital city i feel
very lost says andrea vera gajardo a
mathematician at the university of
alprazo who volunteered as an electoral
observer i don't understand the choice
chile made chile
my gut tells me that fear won says
barbara rojas ayala an astronomer at the
university of tarapaqa and arika
apologies for the pronunciations who
endorsed the letter
in addition to bolstering science the
proposed charter suggested drastic
changes to chile's economic and
political systems that people weren't
ready for she says
if accepted the draft constitution would
replace the current version put in place
in 1980 during the military dictatorship
of augusto pinochet
so further in this article
we have a slight counterpoint to the
apparent embrace by all scientists
in chile um
which here we go uh felipe
paredes a chilean biochemist at emory
university in atlanta georgia was one of
the millions of people who disliked the
proposed document he agreed with some of
it such as the way it prioritized social
and human rights but he also felt things
were missing for example the draft did
not include any mention of funding for
science
i needed a clear signal that there was
going to be more investment i did not
see that paredes says
so uh oh and he he proceeds he also
wanted to see explicit protection of
patents and industrial property rights
which is included in the current
constitution
so
there's at least a little bit of
indication here in this nature article
that maybe this is not
exactly as it is being as it is being
described
and when you
click through on that article you find
another one from nature from july 28
2022 of this year
in which they say chile proposes new
constitutions steeped in science
although many researchers support the
draft opposition could sink it so for
two articles here nature is saying this
constitution is about science basically
fauci asks if you're opposed to this
constitution you're opposed to science
if you don't like this constitution
you're saying that you don't like
science a vote against this constitution
is a vote against science i am
making up these particular things but
that is clearly the message uh that we
are being sent by nature again one of
the top two tier top two
science journals in the world
uh and it began this piece begins oh
actually let me go in to the one that i
have
um highlighted oh
didn't work this piece begins chile has
a new best seller since it was finalized
on the fourth of july interesting
a draft of what could become the
nation's constitution has commanded
massive numbers of online downloads and
crowds waiting to buy paperback copies
they may become one of the most read
texts in chile in recent times says
jimena baez baez president of the
country's national association of
postgraduate researchers who is based in
valparaiso
so
again this this piece published in
nature uh indicates how totally
different it is uh from the standing
constitution which was put in place in
1980
and
uh
while it doesn't really point to
anything in particular it does keep
saying it's all about science science
science science so
i
had to work a little bit to find it i
found it it's of course in spanish
i had it translated and
again i was hoping to show you some of
the some of the translation but i'm
going to walk us through a little bit of
what is in here
first of all it's really long
and it really doesn't seem like any of
the media including frankly the nature
articles but you know this is this has
been covered by cnn msnbc has been
covered all over the place it doesn't
really seem like anyone has actually
read it which is
not that uncommon but it is a bit of a
problem if they're going to continue to
repeat the talking points of this is
about science this is a science
constitution it's not uncommon at all
but it is completely unforgivable
journalistically speaking the idea that
they are going to report on it without
having read it is appalling and opens
the door to all kinds of skullduggery
where you know the label on the box
doesn't match the contents that's right
and i will say that the uh the actual
text of the of the constitution is 388
articles many of which are or have many
many sub sub points
and i did not read the entire thing i
read in detail the first 70 of them and
then i searched on the document
for all occurrences of the word science
scientists
scientific and also climate because
climate seems to be the thing that is
most most what people are talking about
when they say that this is a this is a
science heavy science pro science piece
uh so i'm just gonna i'm gonna walk us
through
uh
a few of the things that i find in the
in the first
fifth of the articles and then point out
every you know what happens in every
single instance of when some form of the
word science shows up in the in the
translated version of the proposed
constitution which again has been voted
down
article six
uh let's see i was hoping to show you
guys let me find it article six
i'm gonna find it
apologies guys
come on
wow is this going slowly
just scrolling scrolling scrolling i'm
not sure what's going on
um
article six which is pretty high up in
this piece
the state promotes a society in which
women men sexual and gender diversity
and dissidents participate in conditions
of substantive equality
recognizing their effective
representation as a principle and a
minimum condition for the full and
substantive exercise of democracy and
citizenship
well right away we have the use of some
very modern political language uh that
doesn't actually have any basis in
science
there's nothing exactly anti-scientific
there yet
and i did go back and forth when the
translation was a little weird and and
looked at the original and
um
and this does this this is clearly an uh
a reference to uh
to
gender identity and to a conflation of
gender identity with sex and we will see
later on some of the some of the
demonstrations of that so
right away i'm unconvinced that this is
actually all that focused on what we
understand to be true scientifically and
the second
point in article six of again the new
chilean constitution that the newly
proposed but voted down chilean
constitution
is all state collegiate bodies
autonomous constitutional bodies senior
and executive bodies of the
administration as well as the boards of
directors of public and semi-public
enterprises must have a parody
composition that ensures that at least
50 percent of their members are women
now that has nothing to do with science
but it is
uh rather a remarkable and uh and
heavy-handed attempt
to fix
a problem that many actually don't even
see as particularly a problem at this
point
it may or may not be a problem but
what is definitely a problem is the idea
that you can simply impose an arbitrary
um
degree of presence that signals a
healthy system and let's
let's talk about that though because
when you say arbitrary some people will
immediately say well but it's the sex
ratio it's a one-to-one sex ratio
therefore we need fifty percent while
they say at least fifty percent of their
members being women um but it's
arbitrary because
well it's arbitrary for a number of
different reasons one you don't know how
much interest there is in joining these
things two you don't know that the sex
ratio is 50 50 at adulthood
um it and so if you were going to try to
write this carefully what you would say
was that it was at parity with
the
population
right you would not assign a number to
it well i think that's a weak argument
you know the sex ratio tends yes it
tends to skew more towards women as a
population ages because men tend to die
younger for a number of reasons but
partially because people were holding
their beers and and the men were allowed
to go do ridiculous things that may or
may not work out on what could go wrong
right one of your favorite reddit
journals i gather um and but but i i
really think that that's
that's a that's a quite a trivial point
that sex ratio is more or less one to
one
and
uh
what you know what the real issue here
is
is that as as i have written about
extensively and as we wrote about in a
hundred gatherers guide and as i have
talked about in various places
uh time and again what we find is when
you strip away
barriers to access barriers to choice
such that women are as girls are as free
as possible to choose to go into things
like stem like science technology
engineering and math
the freer the girls and women are the
less likely they are to choose those
things that you find
not not that no women choose those
things of course they do and of course
the best engineer in the world at any
given point in time might be a woman and
you should expect there will be some
women in those fields but the idea that
you should expect that the that the
number of women interested in say civil
engineering will be equal to the number
of men interested in civil engineering
is
anti-scientific actually well and even
worse is the fact that if you take any
category and you assign it a percentage
of the target group right
you are automatically reducing the
overall capacity of the thing and the
the problem is there's a booby trap here
right if you say well if you're going to
say 50 of the whatever it is must be
women that you will reduce the quality
that you are implying that women are of
lower quality than men no
the same thing would be true if you said
50 at least must be men or 50 at least
must be white people or 50 at least must
be any group the point is what you want
to do
if you want to increase the capacity of
the committee or the school or whatever
it is is
basically establish a merit-based system
in which you pick the most qualified
people yes that can be a problem if
there is
differential access to the things that
make you highly qualified but the point
is
so-called equity
is intention
it is in tension with the
uh capacity of the resulting
graduates or the resulting
capacity of whatever entity you're
trying to make equitable right so
in writing a constitution this way they
are deciding to prioritize one thing
over another which is capability and so
it is not obvious that
scientifically speaking one would make
that choice there is at least a
discussion that has to be had about
which is the highest value do you want
the capacity of the thing to be highest
by taking whoever is best and putting
them on the entity or do you want uh the
degree to which it uh
achieves parity do you want to
prioritize that
exactly
uh so
there are a couple more i'm just i'm
going to ask if our producer who is
letting a cat in at the moment can maybe
get us some wire while he's up
thank you
um
there's some good stuff in here so we're
gonna we're gonna hit some of the low
points for sure and i think the one that
i just read is one of the low points but
article eight for instance in
translation says
individuals and peoples are
interdependent with nature and form an
inseparable whole with it
the state recognizes and promotes good
living as a relationship of harmonious
balance between people nature and the
organization of society
they also
say
uh let's see article 14.
chile's international relations as an
expression of its sovereignty are based
on respect for international law and the
principles of self-determination of
peoples non-intervention and matters
within the domestic jurisdiction of
states multilateralism solidarity
cooperation political autonomy and legal
equality among states and skipping
forward a little bit within article 14
chile declares latin america and the
caribbean as a priority area in its
international relations it is committed
to maintaining the region as a zone of
peace and freedom from violence
it promotes regional political social
cultural economic and productive
integration among states and facilitates
cross-border contact and cooperation
among indigenous peoples this makes a
lot of sense for a south american
country i have to say that i'm troubled
by something here and it isn't the
content of those concepts
it is what they are doing in a
constitution now i can't say it's a very
long document i understand that but
maybe the purpose of the very long
document is to
um
hide something with teeth in a lot of
stuff that has no teeth that sounds
right to certain ears right the whole
idea that nature
a publication which has increased this
isn't nature i understand that but the
whole idea that nature
is
uh arguing that this is a pro-science
constitution and that it's tragic
that the population of chile has
rejected it is absurd coming from nature
right which has recently taken up arms
against real science in favor of
virtue signaling
and my point would be maybe the whole
reason that whatever team it is that is
portraying itself as the team of science
while in fact undermining science it
wants something out of this document and
the question is well you know it's a
needle in a haystack where is the thing
with teeth that it really wants there's
a lot of needles and haystacks here um i
don't think that's the one i think that
that struck me as a a well-written like
okay we're actually going to acknowledge
that we care more about the region that
we are in then we do care about things
on the opposite side opposite side of
the world
so let's uh let's
move on
um
article
26.2 somewhere in here
uh you know they've got stuff
it's anti-death penalty
no person shall be subjected to enforced
disappearance that seems like directly
responsive to pin or shape
that's that was in article 22
article 26
section 2
um
the state has the priority duty to
promote respect and guarantee the rights
of children and adolescents safeguarding
their best interests their progressivity
their comprehensive development and
their right to be heard and to
participate in and influence all matters
affecting them
great
but
the priority duty to promote respect and
guarantee the rights of children and
adolescents including their
comprehensive development seems
a little bit out of out of whack with
what we are soon going to see is a lot
of language uh basically denying the
biological
reality of sex
specifically article
30.3 again in the
uh in the voted down proposed new
constitution for chile article 30
subpoint 3
the translation reads as follows
women and pregnant women and pregnant
women have the right before during and
after childbirth to have access to the
health services they require to
breastfeed and to maintain a direct and
permanent link with their daughter or
son taking into consideration the best
interest of children adolescents well
that's strange right
women and pregnant women and pregnant
women
but when you go to the
uh translate to the original which
their their nonsense language through
the translation algorithm exactly
couldn't figure out what the hell was
being said yes wow that's beautiful
actually las mujeres personas
so women and pregnant people have
rights
is what it says in this in the spanish
and pregnant people isn't a thing right
it's pregnant women and really all they
have to say is women or
uh pregnant women yeah
but what they say is women and pregnant
people
and
you could argue that of course they mean
women but actually of course they don't
what they mean is it's women who've
declared themselves men but have decided
to get pregnant anyway
and that
actually fully reveals that they are
women
and that they aren't
men
and
that in a piece that is being touted by
the mainstream media and the major
science journals on the planet in a
document that is supposedly all about
science tells us that we are in a
political landscape that is so full of
landmines it's going to be hard to find
the science to get our to get us out
frankly
yeah no it's um
let's put it this way i would say
any
failure
to
write clearly with respect to something
as fundamental as this is an indication
that what you are dealing with is at
best highly compromised in a scientific
regard if not null and void in other
words it's one thing to say this
constitution should or should not have
been passed but to tout it as a
pro-science constitution if it's really
about this new
uh anti-scientific
vogue is insane
and not surprising
yes
not surprising at this moment and not
surprising that a journal that should be
saying this has been touted as a
pro-science constitution but within it
there are many things that actually fly
in the face of what science has
correctly revealed about the universe
that it is showing up on the opposite
side and
basically pretending that chileans have
embraced primitivism
uh and rejected sciences you know it's
the height of irony yep
that's right
um you know we've got stuff about
indigenous peoples being allowed to uh
keep and grow their own seeds into
perpetuity that's awesome
we've got um protections for seasonal
workers we've got the right to
collective bargaining there's some good
stuff in here
there's some eminent domain
things that i'm not sure about state
guarantees the event this is in
article 51
the state guarantees the availability of
the land necessary for the provision of
decent adequate housing it administers
an integrated public land system with
powers to prior to prioritize the use
management and disposal of public land
for purposes of social interest and the
acquisition of private land in
accordance with the law
yeah this is one of these things that
a functioning society absolutely needs
these rights but a pathological society
is guaranteed to abuse them and so it's
really hard to know how to write
a constitution
such that you protect the people's right
to
uh
basically buy land that is necessary for
necessary to acquire for the public good
while protecting the rights of people to
own land and not have that power you
know used against them punitively or
on behalf of
you know
corporate profit or something like that
um so yes it's hard to know it's it's
one of the genuinely difficult issues in
writing such a document that's right
uh article
61.2
the state
this this this makes me particularly
upset because it conflates
uh
well you'll see the state guarantees
it's exercise without discrimination
the so the translation is weird here but
i don't think it gets in the way of what
is intended but it's it's not quite
right the state guarantees its exercise
without discrimination with a gender
perspective inclusion and cultural
relevance as well as access to
information education health and the
services and benefits required for it
ensuring all women and persons with the
capacity to bear children the conditions
for a pregnancy a voluntary interruption
of pregnancy of voluntary and protected
childbirth and maternity
so you've got
gender ideology with women and persons
with the capacity to bear children
that's
women who have the capacity to bear
children because men don't not all women
have the capacity to bear children but
only women have the capacity to bear
children so there's that little bit of
nonsensical non-scientific
anti-scientific anti-scientific garbage
in there but then they've got
reproductive rights and then they
they're basically putting into the
constitution
the right to abortion they don't use the
word in the original either but
and so they're you know they're being a
little little squidgy about it without
using the word and i and i'm sure that
that was part of the objection among
some voters
but
i really wish
that
reproductive rights uh
about which we um
disagree with many on the right would
stop being conflated with the idea that
men could get pregnant
it makes the left look like they are
entirely like we are entirely completely
out to lunch utter lunatics
i wouldn't mind going out to lunch but
um
back on the topic at hand
i want to try to put this in context
because it is not a minor issue that
this document in the middle of trying to
define a right is going to kowtow
to a momentary anti-scientific fashion
yes it is like imagine that you go
to the evolution conference
and the let's say that i don't know
there's a important lecture
in paper being presented on the
evolution of bats i'm going to choose
bats simply because i know something
about their evolution but
imagine that the person
presenting this work was to say
uh you know
when the chiroptera emerges into the
fossil record
50 million years ago praise be to the
lord
it was essentially fully formed right
now this is true the fossils that show
up 50 million years ago if bats were
fully formed implying that there's a
process of evolution that was not
captured by the fossil record we can
talk about why but to the extent that
the talk on the fossil record
and the evolution of bats includes an
allusion to a creator for those who may
think that that's important invalidates
the talk right it suggests that this is
not a scientific exercise that this is
an exercise in something social and
while it may be important to
have gratitude to some mythical creator
for some purpose it doesn't belong in a
scientific conference and it's this
confusion over who can give birth and
how we protect their rights it's like we
must protect the rights of women who
we're now confused about yes it's like
well i don't really accept that you're
going to be good at protecting them what
you've written here is compromised in
its ability to protect them because you
have sabotaged the definition for some
purpose that has to do with you know uh
i don't know
uh rubbing shoulders with people at the
cocktail party that you like right that
doesn't belong in a constitution and
you know again i would say
there are certain documents if you were
if you were buying a house for example
and you were reading in your loan
document
and there was a certain
political
uh statement just interspersed with the
provisions of how the thing worked it's
like okay now i'm walking away from this
loan document i don't know why that's in
there but the fact is i know that it's
being in there is alarming yep right and
i'm out i'm going to look for another
lender right
so
you know
somehow the people of chile
seem to have spotted a compromised
document and rejected it in spite
apparently strong pressure to embrace it
as the modern scientific thing to do and
you know good on them for for noticing
right
absolutely
um
more every person has the right to the
free development and full recognition of
his or her identity in all its
dimensions and manifestations including
sexual characteristics gender identities
and expressions name and sex affective
orientations
which sounds awesome except when
combined exactly with what you're saying
with the other things
in here
but they've got death with dignity
article 68
okay they've got the constitution
ensures the right of people to make free
and informed decisions about their care
and treatment at the end of life
great
article 69 everyone has the right to
freedom of movement and
freedom of movement to reside stay and
travel anywhere in the national
territory as well as to enter and leave
it
the law shall regulate the exercise of
this right
what
that's that's the article and it's in
its entirety and i went and looked i
thought
i feel like chile had lockdowns i feel
actually restricted movement and so it
did
so an art of a bbc article from june of
2021
and i fact checked this against some
others santiago capital city imposed
stay-at-home orders in response to
rising coveted cases i think santiago's
the capital must be yeah
so a little over a year ago santiago
imposed stay at home orders in response
to rising coveted cases
and the article was funny because it was
just shocked because despite really high
rates of vaccination code was climbing
and they still they were going to need
to lock everyone down stay at home
orders okay so i don't actually know if
this article in the constitution article
69 which says your freedom of movement
shall not be restricted except unless
we're going to restrict it basically um
is
maybe
just saying we're going to still be able
to do that to you or if it's actually a
response to that and they're saying yeah
we're not going to do that anymore i
can't i there's no way for me to tell
because i wasn't in on this and but did
i did i say also that this was created
this was a citizen created document
which
is all the rage in some circles now but
this wasn't created by
people who were elected well let me
point out citizen created document means
what exactly how do you prevent somebody
who is representing some other interest
from
participating well i think i think it it
it stands in for
oh boy this that you know this is likely
to have been a
uh a process that is not what it seems
right and the provision that you just
read in which
the right to freely move about is
nominally protected in the same sentence
as that sentence
or yes in the same article uh stanza
let's say okay um in the same stanza as
the
mechanism by which that right will be
circumvented yes right is again well
the
it is
a signal that somebody is interested in
pretending one thing
you know signaling one direction and
going the other direction yeah and
now this this struck me you know this is
not about science right but this one
article 69 here struck me as the perfect
synopsis of
the of the problem overall with this
document like okay
your words sound great and in this case
they sound really good even if you look
closely
but you're going to undermine them right
away in this case such that your words
actually mean nothing
well everyone has the right to freedom
of movement the law shall regulate the
exercise of this right
do you or do you not have freedom of
movement well when we say you do you do
and this is
very similar to
biden's
philadelphia speech in which
it could be read as a patriotic
embrace of our founding rights right
except where it comes to mega
republicans right i mean
you know
why would we agree that mega republicans
have those rights those people you know
clear and present danger they're clear
and present danger and so you know
speech rights are all well and good but
you know
can't take them too far
um you know so
yeah
let's put it this way i think the way
especially in light of something like a
constitution which exists above
the level of standard law yeah
one ought to have an alarm bell standard
right if your alarm bells are going off
especially in multiple places in the
document
it's null and void it doesn't matter how
much good stuff is in there right right
it's null and void because somebody who
who constructed it either was unclear on
how to protect rights or wasn't really
interested in doing it right and that's
and that's part of why i bring up the
idea that it was citizen created
like why
why would you try to frame a
constitution with that as
as the method by which you you do it you
want citizen input but that's what the
voting is about
well there's a question about how to do
this and this is
an issue that's arising in in the us as
well
i have long said that
we are in need of a constitutional
convention
because our founding documents have the
right idea but they're not up to the
modern challenges
however
there's no way we can afford a
constitutional convention it will be a
disaster if it happens
um and so
you know it isn't clear how you get
in modern times it's not clear how you
get to that process without corruption
or insanity taking it over right um and
it's a i think it's a question we need
to answer because
you know these
increasingly antiquated documents
or in the case of chile uh documents
compromised by the era of their founding
uh
they're not up to the challenge of of
modern times indeed
okay uh so about at this point in
reading this i knew i was going to run
out of time and so i did this search on
all instances of
of forms of the word science and found
not very many not very many cases
uh three instances of the word science
or sciences seven of the word scientific
and then a few of the word climate
uh many of them are in article 98
which uh my my translation here uh
somehow garbled the numbers i don't know
why the numbers wouldn't have shown up
well but um so let me just make sure i'm
reading the right one here
cncs
yes
yeah here we go article 98.
sciences and technologies their
applications and research processes must
be developed according to the bioethical
principles of solidarity cooperation
responsibility and with full respect for
human dignity animal sentience the
rights of nature and the other rights
established in this constitution and an
international human rights treaties
ratified an in force in chile
animal sentience
this
strikes me
as you know maybe the maybe article 98
is the main thing that nature and the
other you know that they saw and went
like oh it's a pro science it's science
forward it's
this document is all about science
but this broad
sweeping statement with a bunch of terms
that are ill-defined
and let's see in the original um
yeah prince principios
bioeticos
i don't know what a bioethical principle
of solidarity is solidarity with uh
flatworms on the basis of their
sentience which is uh
well understood in certain circles i
guess but well corals too but not
mushrooms
not yeah
through the mushrooms no speaking of
lunch you know
are we vegan now
i don't i think mushrooms are i guess
they're well you just like if if
speaking of lunch means mushrooms i
don't like i when i think of lunch i
often think of that's because i'm saying
that you are not in solidarity with the
centuries of well i mean i picked ham i
did i just said that like you know
that's a sentient animal yes that
actually like you know we we should all
consider this is you know part of the
value of
understanding
what you're eating and not just having
it come cellophane wrapped from the
store and having no relationship with it
at all like that
pigs are incredibly smart yes and flat
worms aren't none that i've talked to
have impressed me is that what you're
doing late at night
yes
over the internet for the most part but
um yeah yeah on the internet nobody
knows you're referring you're a flat
worm indeed indeed um yeah no it's
there's so much signaling in here and i
mean i guess what it really says
even if this document is completely
organic the product of well-intentioned
citizens trying to write a new
constitution because the old one sucks
right
that is
you know about the nicest thing we can
say
they have demonstrated
even just in the small number of
examples that you have raised
that they don't
have the gist of what has to be true of
a constitution for it to stand up right
well to be fair you know i'm i skipped a
bunch of the early stuff that is sort of
foundational you know there there is
some material in here
i i i don't want to suggest that i have
i have revealed the entire structure of
this document it doesn't matter i would
say again the question is
you've got deal breakers where vague
things that appear
to suggest something that ought to
govern the way law functions are
presented in a way that
you know they can be abused they can be
weaponized right they can be used to
negate the very rights that are being
described and yes uh all i would say is
look this constitution writing stuff is
really difficult right because you're
writing a document for a future you have
not yet seen which means it cannot
afford any fat you're going to make
mistakes you have to write a document
that places those in a position to
interpret it with the power
to do what is intended without the
potential to be abused with the ability
to amend the document so that errors
that become obvious can be addressed but
that the temptation
to change it uh meets a viscosity that
prevents it from being changed
willy-nilly
these are difficult tasks
and
all i would say is a the length of the
document if there's lots of stuff in
there that is weird or
didn't need to be said is really just
about you know what we like what we
aspire to
right that stuff shouldn't be in there
because it's all architecture that can
be used to unhook the protections that
must be at the core of a constitution
yeah
so
i'm still looking for
the science in here right um science and
technologies
must be developed according to the
bioethical principles of solidarity
cooperation like that's about what the
goals of the scientists have to be like
what what their over underlying
principles have to be i still don't see
the science part so let me just walk
through here
every single example that my search
reveals
we have
article 178
and this is a slightly out of order
because of the way that i did the
searches
uh paraphrasing the state shall use
advances in science to make life better
for people
okay
vague yeah vague better for current
people at the expense of future people
right vague at best article 220 which is
about the autonomous region
uh which is a a political
entity within the landscape of chile
with regard to the autonomous region the
development of science is to be
considered a competency so just like
this list of things that ought to be
thought about in developing the
autonomous region
has nothing to do with actually
encouraging science
uh article
95
article 95 is an interesting one
actually
the
or no it's not uh the constitution
ensures to every person the protection
of copyright over his intellectual
scientific and artistic works
that's it that's again not science uh
and it is the duty it continues later on
of the state to stimulate promote and
strengthen the development of scientific
and technological research in all areas
of knowledge
maybe that's it maybe that's what
they're that's what everyone's on about
it is the duty of the state to stimulate
promote and strengthen the development
of scientific and technological research
in all areas of knowledge
thus contributing to the socio-cultural
enrichment of the country and the
improvement of the living conditions of
its inhabitants but again how and what
kind of science and how will it get
funded how do you guarantee that it gets
funded and how
how will you guarantee that the people
asking questions that you don't like or
coming up with answers that you don't
like are still allowed to do their work
if what they're doing is science or it's
not about science at all this is about a
political agenda
the last few the last few
uh instances of science or science some
form of the word science being mentioned
in this constitution
article 35
education is indispensable this is a
paraphrase in part because it
contributes to scientific technological
economic and cultural activity
article 61 the state recognizes and
guarantees the rights of individuals to
benefit from scientific progress
okay
article 127
the state should adopt an ecologically
responsible administration and promote
environmental and scientific education
but article 128 which immediately
follows that reveals the political
nature of what is meant here because
they're using phrases like environmental
justice and climate action
so i think actually that that is the
core of what is going on with this being
promoted as a pro-science document it's
a
like like i said and you know this i'm
saying nothing about what i think or
what is actually true about the state of
climate science climate in the world the
changing climate whether it's
anthropogenic anything
if what you have is a incredibly long
document that has as one of its core
values
the idea that the conclusion that is
currently arrived at by those climates
by some group of scientists who are
allowed to speak
that their conclusions
are to be raised up into perpetuity
in a document that makes a document
scientific no that doesn't make a
document scientific that makes a
document conclusion driven
so
this reminds me actually we were having
a conversation with toby about her son
our son who is studying the declaration
of independence
and i made an argument to him that the
declaration of independence is an
extremely important document in part
because it is so unusual and
the way in which it is unusual i think
our founders
solved the problem that the authors of
this document whoever they may be
either deliberately failed to or
just happen to have failed to solve
the declaration of independence
does not pretend to know
how to do what it knows needs to be done
it describes what needs to be done as
this document attempts to in several
places
right but it does not pretend to be the
document that lays out the structure
and by separating these two things by
saying look when in the course of human
events
right this that and the other here are
the things that we must do right but it
doesn't say how and then the how
document is very carefully architected
there are errors in it but
are you arguing that this is basically
trying to play the role of both the
declaration of independence and the
united states concept well i have to
tell you the bill of rights like is are
you is that what you're look
i'm an alarm bell guy right yeah i see
stuff coming
it's not always there but i am very
alarmed by attempts at civilization
architecting that have
lots of room for abuse in them so this
document definitely uh
sets off enough alarm bells that i'm
like oh boy that's a that's a loser
right there so i don't know what they
were trying to do i don't know if it's
an organic effort that just screwed up
or it's a non-organic effort which i
suspect
but
but the point is
by fusing these two things you create
the undoing of the structure by the the
what from the how those are the the the
what from the the what and the why right
we aspire to a fair society here are the
rules we're going to lay out because we
consider these rights inalienable right
and the point is you don't need to amend
the declaration of independence it is
timeless right it may be wrong in
certain places but in general the point
is here's what we stand for and then how
the hell are we going to do this you can
upend you could constitutional
convention an entire new document about
how we're going to do it but the point
is this is still how we got here and why
we had to do it and
the the
um now failed
new chilean constitution
is so muddy
in the parts what you've read is so
muddy in its
understanding of what it's trying to
accomplish that when it talks about how
to accomplish it's like you haven't even
you're you're protecting women and other
people who can get pregnant right like i
don't think if you're if you're honestly
gonna say we're gonna protect women and
other people who can get pregnant i
don't think you're up to the challenge
of saying how to do it yeah right i
think you've just told us you're not yep
that's right
uh so let me just wrap this up on
a
slightly high note or at least a better
note which is the last two
occurrences of some form of the word
science that i find and then and that's
it unless search completely failed on me
that's it in terms of what's in the
supposedly science-heavy document
we have in article 135
uh that they will cooperate
internationally in space research for
peaceful and scientific purposes that's
charming i like that i prove yeah
and article 240
quote
from the translation the state shall
conserve protect and care for antarctica
through a policy based on knowledge and
oriented towards scientific research
international collaboration and peace
and this is you know for those who don't
realize where chile is this makes
perfect sense of course chile cares
about and has a stake in antarctica and
i would i hadn't predicted it but cool
it gets its own article in this
constitution which failed as it should
have but i like that it had an article
in this constitution yeah
i guess a couple things are
being surfaced by
this exploration
one is that we have fallen into
a
because humans now have a kind of remote
relationship to the conduct of science
because science has become so
technological
we are defaulting now into
team science i'm on team science against
its opponents and team science isn't
very scientific in fact it's often
anti-scientific team science super blue
super blue yeah and so no science had a
color shouldn't science encompass all
the colors
but
the problem is that people do not know
what to do
with their
noble desire to be on the scientific
team when when all teams are not
scientific many people correctly want to
be on the scientific team but they don't
really understand what does
you know that looks like science but it
isn't and this may not look like science
but it is that's a hard thing um to
to deal with and likewise when it comes
to something like a constitution
people do not know how to evaluate it
right
the you know
or the constitution well there are a lot
of good things in this constitution and
then there's some things i can't
interpret and then there are a few
things that alarm me right oh that's a
dead constitution right there that's a
constitution you can't touch and it's a
little like you know well that's a
that's a pretty nice sculpture of a
horse
yeah but it's got an army in it okay but
the sculpture's good you know it's like
well
no that's a disguise for an army that's
not a sculpture of a horse right the
reason you know it was a gift
all right it's a gift and you wouldn't
want to look in the mouth and find the
army inside you know i mean
it's just
certain look science
does not it's two different it's
completely different completely
different which i have i've i'm feeling
my brain
disarray
no it has to do with a failure of
gratitude and you're looking at his
teeth to see whether it's healthy yeah
um okay right
so
anyway the point is science and [ __ ]
that happens in a lab but is about
something else like profit or politics
those things look alike to somebody
who's not
pretty good at science frankly right you
can you can dress something up to look
like science and it can have nothing to
do with science or it can be
anti-scientific and so lab coats are
cheap
lab coats are cheap oh that's good it's
easy to dress up like science it
absolutely is yeah um
and it's also easy for people who went
into science to get dragged into
something that isn't science but still
uses
beakers or you know
you know i should i recently because we
moved as we
told you all last week um i ran into a
bunch of my
field gear but in with my field gear was
some of my lab gear because i used to
teach comparative anatomy back in the
days when we were professors and so i
have a couple lab coats and i have my
dissecting tools and i feel like
putting on my lab coat and wielding my
scalpel and you know given some really
science-ish but actually anti-scientific
pronouncements
yeah i don't love the scalpel part it's
just okay i'll use a
i can't even remember the names for any
of my other tools at the moment but i'll
use something else machete butter knife
neither a machete nor a butter knife
show up in my dissecting kit guys
it's similar to a scalpel yeah that's
dangerous
true unless you're butter okay i'll use
a blunt probe how about that blunt probe
perfect yes perfect there it is
um that is
that's
that's what where i landed on the
chilean constitution yeah
um well it's quite it's quite the thing
and i wonder if it's not um
the
first instance of something we
increasingly have to be
uh
alarmed and aware of is the tendency
especially in a world where almost the
only thing protecting us are these
antiquated documents that don't quite
work but nonetheless spelled certain
stuff out so clearly that you know it's
still difficult to get in the way of
people's speech rights it's still
awkward for example
um yeah and so i guess we have to be
alert to the the alteration of these
last vestiges of a functional world
absolutely so let me actually let me
let me wrap it up this way by going back
to
this article in nature again there were
two of them that i talked about and i'll
post them in the show notes the one from
july 28th
before it was voted on
in a in a section called boosting
science so this this is nature's having
having seen having supposedly read
this
this document that i was just
revealing highlights of
similar to the current constitution the
proposal mandates that the state
stimulate science and technology crucial
for a country that for the past decade
has consistently invested less than
point four percent of its gross domestic
product in the fields so two points
there similar to the current
constitution so there's no change there
and second point is as i already
commented as one of the scientists the
chilean scientists who didn't like this
commented in one of these pieces
there's without a guarantee of funding
for science what exactly
is this protecting right so
that's not boosting science nature
itself in this editorial has said
similar to the current constitution and
it says but it goes further by adding
that scientific achievements and
technical technological solutions should
be used to improve the life of chileans
for example one of its article states
says that the state should rely on
science to ensure the continuous
improvement of public services and goods
that's the evidence that nature is
providing and you know that's one of the
articles that i read to you guys um
that's the evidence that nature is
providing that this is a science forward
science heavy document and it's
it's
so weak yeah and it's worse than a week
yeah it's at best empty yeah
yeah and actually it it connects us to
the next place we're gonna go actually
well no you're thinking of two two steps
two steps down but um
one more quote from this july article in
nature
soledad bertelson a legal researcher at
the university of los angeles in
santiago worries at the proposed draft
again this is the one that was just
voted down worries that the proposed
draft lacks any mention of intellectual
property rights which are guaranteed in
the current constitution
it is an explicit step backward she says
adding that entrepreneurs might decide
to move their investments out of chile
and using that word entrepreneurs there
will make it seem to many naive readers
of nature who think that they're purists
and scientists and they don't know oh
well i'm not a business person so i
don't care like actually intellectual
property rights matter to anyone who
produces intellectual property anyone
who comes up with ideas
that have the potential to be stolen and
used by other people so that they can
profit from it
so the idea that the current
constitution actually does have
intellectual property rights uh
protections and this one does not
what the hell were they thinking
yeah and it's the kind of thing like
imagine that there was some
multi-billion dollar something at stake
in chile that you could write a big
confusing document that had a lot of uh
you know signals uh
towards vague claims of environmental
sustainability justice protecting the
rights of children and yada yada yada
yeah and really the point is oh yeah
it's all there as a lost leader to drag
in this change in in chilean law that
you know benefits i don't know who but
yeah no i mean and so one of the
articles i didn't read is they
definitely are opposed to slavery
and now you know anyone who voted
against this like
yeah voted against
the abolition of slavery
oh my god this again right like this
this rhetorical trick again over and
over and over again
uh so before we get to talking about
myopia yeah which is uh where i know you
thought we were going next i just want
to say something briefly and this is
actually apropos that article 6 of the
constitution from chile that just got
voted down which uh basically demanded
uh 50 or more female representation at
all public and even some semi-public
organizations boards it was worded
strangely i don't remember exactly
meanwhile in
again an article in nature although it's
not somehow yeah in nature september 8
2022
we have a nature news piece called how
we boosted our numbers of female faculty
members
three researchers in australia offer
lessons from an affirmative recruitment
initiative for women
i'm just going to read a few sections
from this
in 2016 alex
ozark
apologies for the pronunciation who was
then head of the school of mathematics
and statistics undertook an affirmative
action strategy also known as positive
discrimination to recruit women as
faculty members this was a controversial
move but it was prompted by a clear lack
of diversity in the school
comment it was controversial
but the motives were good yeah
sorry it was controversial but one side
was wrong well no actually i mean okay
but my point is it was controversial but
they met well it was controversial but
we were trying to do the right thing
okay trying to do the right thing
doesn't mean the thing that you ended up
doing was the right thing
recognizing there is a pro so there's
two different issues here is there a
problem
we might disagree on that and is the
solution that you propose to this
problem the correct solution
in this case actually i think i think
that i disagree with both the fact that
there is a problem that needs to be
solved here because we're already moving
so far so fast in the right direction
and that the idea that the solution is
what you're about to hear
the strategy was designed as a catalyst
for change it aims specifically to
increase the number of women in faculty
positions improve the professorial
pipeline and provide female role models
for students
only women were eligible to apply for
positions in areas in which women were
underrepresented
they literally created
tenure tracks stem that's science
technology engineering and math faculty
lines for which only women could apply
that is
batshit crazy that is just wrong on so
many levels
but get this here's the next thing that
i've got highlighted in this piece again
published september 8 2022
in nature
many of the successful applicants
reported that they would not have
applied had recruitment been open to
both men and women suggesting a
perceived bias against female candidates
in open recruitment
any
woman in stem who can get a faculty
appointment
i don't i don't even know i i don't even
know what to say well the idea that
sorry but like
the idea that you that you
got
a job
only that you would not have applied to
had you been in competition against the
entire relevant candidate pool
and that you're so okay with this that
you said it and it's now in an article
about how awesome this initiative is
well
that's ridiculous and those people like
perceived bias against female candidates
in open recruitment
even if there was a perceived bias
against female candidates and open
recruitment which frankly i no longer i
yes in the past of course there has been
we know this this is long since
understood right of course there has
been but the idea that there's a
perceived bias now i don't buy maybe in
a few rare places in a few fields a few
a few old dudes who are still on
committees sure right but he perceived
bias against female candidates and open
recruitment means you wouldn't apply for
the job are you kidding me
how are you going to do science how are
you going to be good at doing science if
you won't apply when you think that
there might be something that's not
quite fair in the application process
what is wrong with you all right two
points one
that bias which no longer exists in any
significant degree is going to be
created it's going to be reinvented by
this because the point is to the extent
that you have these initiatives they do
open questions of competence would you
have would you have been in that
position if you had been in competition
with as you say the full range of people
from the field i don't know i wouldn't
have applied
right um but the other thing is
if you go back and read that statement
the one i just read yeah many of the
successful applicants reported that they
would not have applied had recruitment
been open to both men and women
suggesting suggesting a perceived bias
against female candidates and open
recruitment suggesting a perceived bias
no
that sentence is is a nonsense it is a
non-sequitur it might imply that but it
could also suggest that these candidates
were savvy enough to understand that
given a limited budget of time they were
more likely to end up in a position if
you'd eliminated half of the field based
on its chromosomal complement or the
kinds of gametes it produces sorry more
than half the field right because these
are fields in which men are
men outnumber women at all of the levels
and we can argue about whether or not
that's due to bias in preschool and
kindergarten and seventh grade and
college and everything uh but frankly i
don't think so right but in this case it
doesn't suggest that right the authors
of the article have suggested that that
was what it implies but there is a
perfectly rational mathematical
explanation for why somebody would apply
to such a position right uh that has
nothing to do with bias at all yep
um
one more quote from this article
on the right which if you could see my
screen here they've got this in nature
this is in nature
affirmative action recruitment tips
bullet points
the fifth bullet point under affirmative
action recruitment tips for those
considering recruitment initiatives with
an element of affirmative action we
offer some important lessons
don't be too specific about sub
disciplines keep your selection criteria
broad to widen the pool of female
applicants
i think it speaks for itself yeah
it's preposterous and it you know
if we go back several years to uh some
of our earlier discussions
not necessarily on darkhorse but
discussions of what this woke revolution
was doing
this um
basically if you imagine a world in
which nothing is actually real so the
quality of your scientists and your
engineers and your pilots and your
doctors doesn't really matter really the
point is hey it's unfair that this field
of brain surgeons uh you know
disproportionately
uh
has
you know swedes
right
and so we're gonna get some people
you're talking about turnips or swedish
people i'm talking about swedish oh wait
are swedes turnips are rutabagas not
sure
i honestly have no
no dog in the fight nor do i have any
inkling about which okay um of the root
vegetables
that
suggests but the point is
you can't just say well you know it's a
tragedy that x group of people isn't
represented in brain surgery or
aviation and say well whatever we have
to do to correct that as soon as
possible is the thing to do the point is
actually no i want really good pilots
and really good brain surgeons and
that's true irrespective of why there's
a bias maybe the bias actually does
reflect some discrimination but we're
gonna have to think very carefully
about how to get some people properly
qualified to do brain surgery and we're
still going to have to assess them based
on merit and some of the people might
have the mind for brain surgery but
they're not going to have the hands for
it and we really want all brain surgeons
who have both the mind and the hands and
aren't afraid of blood and whatever it
is right you can't just
get people into positions and say uh
problem solves because you may have just
caused a different problem like the
bridges are falling down and the brains
don't work after the surgeons get to
them and stuff like that so
you know
i think there's a there's a way in which
this crazy revolutionary movement
does not actually understand that the
world is real that's right right that it
requires
actual
expertise and not just the pretense of
expertise in order to do the difficult
jobs well and that if you
just put people in those positions
because you like the composition of the
room better you may be compromising
something fundamental and functional
about our system however it got that way
yep and that's you know this this is a
drum beat that we have been at for a
long time but hey this this is why we
and others
see in this revolution post-modernism
done badly very very badly and it's at
its roots but also the thing that we
talk about that is that is somewhat
different from that that we talk about
in a hunter-gatherer's guide and
elsewhere
is
that you know sort of one of the
outgrowths of a
frivolous understanding of the
post-modern understanding of the world
that some reality is socially created
is that if all of your world exists in
this social landscape
you may come to imagine that the entire
world exists in a social landscape and
therefore come to imagine that actually
physics isn't real and no no one is
going to say that actually out loud
but you know the example that i like to
use is
the roadrunner cartoons
where when the roadrunner dupes the
coyote
yet again into running off the edge of a
cliff
it's really funny when wiley coyote
doesn't fall until he himself looks down
and recognizes there's no land beneath
him and that therefore gravity should be
affecting him at the point that he comes
to recognize the situation he's in then
he falls stupid coyote
and he does he doesn't fall until then
it's super funny why
because even the three-year-olds
watching that cartoon know that that's
not how gravity works right it's really
funny when it's a cartoon coyote it's
not funny when you're raising your kids
protecting them from all physical stuff
and only giving them social things to
think about and you end up with these
children in the bodies of adults running
around making claims like men can get
pregnant it's it comes from the lack of
experience with the physical world and
some really deep-seated belief even
though they wouldn't say it out loud
that reality isn't real that it can be
negotiated
so like everyone needs to have at least
one skill one set of experiences with
the physical world be it with
hiking or carpentry or even
baking you know some something where you
can't say afterwards
actually it looks like i failed but i
didn't fail here's why
right you we all need that
100 it is the core of an education just
even for common sense yeah
um i do want to point out there's one
thing about the uh the wiley coyote
situation
that i always feel is missing from these
discussions and i'm i'm gonna put it on
the record do it
the interesting the most interesting
thing and i think the funniest thing
about the wiley coyote bit yeah
is that it's not that the physics is all
social it is arbitrarily social right
the roadrunner knows well no no no
the coyote
the physics of friction fails the coyote
as he runs off the cliff the fact that
he continues to run does not continue to
propel him because he has nothing to
push against yeah but gravity requires
his recognition before it kicks in right
so it's like a world in which some
physics is real and some physics is
about your you know accepting of it
and anyway i always find that
juxtaposition absolutely yeah you get
skidding skidding skidding
uh represents
real physical forces yeah the normal
force requires your recognition but the
the static friction of the feet against
the ground
not so much that
that's real yep
all right
finally finally
um
you pointed me just a half an hour
before we came on excuse me um
to an article in uh the upcoming issue
of the atlantic which is available now
yes to which i was appointed by kevin
fothe a friend and long
uh supporter of the podcast and
and our work um in any case it's a very
interesting article also
deeply frustrating i almost feel like it
requires a
paragraph by paragraph um
what's another word for deconstruction
that doesn't involve
deconstruction but it means but we
haven't said you have to describe i will
describe the article here the article is
about
the
growing epidemic of myopia actually
globally
and
i want to start though with a personal
story but it's been particularly noticed
in east and southeast asia in asia yes
and it is now being noticed uh in the
west
and there's a difference in how uh
asians have dealt with it and how it's
being dealt with in the west but just
one more thing before you tell your
story
the standard story among western trained
eye doctors is its genetic
and
somehow it's the very rare
and
and highlighted in this article
uh doctor of ophthalmology who says yeah
but
why then are so many more children
showing up with uh with myopia when
their parents don't necessarily have it
so i would say i would say that a little
differently the story has been that it
was genetic and the rate at which it is
accelerating has forced
those who make that claim to back off it
because it's clearly so impossible right
but the article describes it as like
this is the standard right it has been
but my point is going to be
this was nonsense from the get-go it was
always obvious that was a dumb
explanation and
in any case let me let me tell my little
uh anecdotal story
so
i was a child once and i had
terrible eyesight you know the kind that
makes parents fret and eye doctors uh
discuss exotic solutions okay
i had
an
astigmatism and i was prescribed bifocal
glasses i was a child i had bifocal
glasses i was
sentenced to
exercises in which one eye was to be
patched for half an hour at a time
every day of the week i believe
anyway
here's the thing
um
i was the kind how compliant were you
not even a little
not even yeah shocking knowing me right
but okay so that is a very very sad
story except for what happens next
right
my eyes
completely cure themselves right okay
i've had great eyesight and i went until
uh you know just the cusp of 50 before i
needed to actively
do anything for my reading i could read
i had great distance vision i still have
great distance vision
what happened
well it was obvious to me
that there was something about what we
are all told about eyes that just isn't
right
the story that eyes that were so badly
formed
that they
required all of this elaborate
technology and these
you know ruthless interventions in order
to get them to function well enough for
me to live a normal life
right the fact that that turned out to
be false
is inconsistent with the basic
explanation of how vision works
in other words if my eyes were malformed
as a kid the chances that they would
become well-formed as an adult
are essentially zero right unless you
have a developmental process that has a
feedback in it right
malformed eyes as a kid could be even
more malformed as an adult if whatever
process was off kilter continued to go
off kilter but what happened to me
implies that there is a feedback inside
of development that perceives the
malformation of the eyes and corrects it
okay
what i did not understand because i had
heard the you know well the shape of
your eyes is clearly a genetic
phenomenon blah blah blah
right what i did not understand is the
shape of your eyes yes the basic shape
is specified by the genes but there is
muscular architecture which modifies
these things and if what you do is you
put a corrective lens in front of your
eyes then you're denying your eyes the
information by which they might
self-correct right so
i have been grumbling to myself as you
know for
decades about the fact that the huge
fraction of the population that needs
glasses as kids
um is obviously downstream of the fact
that we are interrupting a developmental
process a we are doing something that is
causing the eyes to be malformed in the
first place very likely that has to do
with an alteration between uh
an alteration of the environment and the
distance at which we typically work you
know a hunter gatherer a child may be
doing a little bit of close work but
they're doing an awful lot of distance
work and we are doing an awful lot of
close work and maybe there's nothing to
be done about that but there's a basic
hyper novelty question here well there's
certainly something to be done about
getting the fact that many people are
getting no distance vision yeah no
difference
this is one of the three things we
advise at the end of every podcast right
get outside
and you know there there are
uh there are competing ideas as as
written in this article about you know
what's the benefit of getting outside
even though all these ophthalmologists
now say yeah you should spend more time
outside is it the bright sunlight or is
it the open spaces like it's probably
both right
well
so there there's also something missing
from this article there's a lot missing
there's a lot missing but um you know
they talk about the fact that you know
people have suspected that the close
work might be a problem but it's
difficult to demonstrate because you
know for every kid who has a problem
whether there's another kid who doesn't
have a problem with yada yada
hypothesis for you
that this feedback involved in
correcting the shape of the eye getting
the eye to be approximately spherical
which it should be rather than oblong
that feedback is also sensitive to what
you are looking at
what is the effect of looking at
something that's this far away from you
that appears to be something very far
away from yes right if you are looking
at a picture of mountains right or you
were looking at a screen on which
mountains are just
displayed
you are sending a completely
inconsistent signal
right you are
maybe there's a flag for oh distant
object oh i'm looking at a distant
object how distant oh it's about
seven or eight inches from my eye you
know so
what does that do to your development
right yeah so
in any case
i want to go back to the article and i
want to talk about a couple of things
just to place it in context i do
recommend people look at this article i
would recommend that they extract the
value from it the description of our
awakening to what we're doing to our
children and the various things that may
be done to prevent this from happening
to children who
haven't yet suffered from this or are
only beginning to right that is a very
useful article but the article is
completely maddening in the way it
portrays this and uh and the way it
effectively
defends the
you know
superstitions of ophthalmology right
into the present where you know we how
many children have we damaged
because we haven't gotten serious about
this until now when it has been obvious
that we we should have been from
from for at least many
decades all right so i wanted to connect
it to
the
dark horse episode in which i talk to
steve patterson about the dark age which
he and i both believe is happening we
have a slightly different take on it but
we had a very good discussion suggest
people watch it
one of the things that i love about
steve's take on the dark age
is he has a list of things that are
contributing
to the darkness right what is blinding
scientists to what is in front of them
and
my favorite of them is he says there is
a chronic tendency to underestimate the
complexity of the system being looked at
right in other words if you have a kind
of
bio 101 textbook view of
physiology and genetics
you have the idea oh there are genes
they describe how to build a person and
uh you know they they basically
blueprint the uh the morphology right so
if your eyes are the wrong shape it's
probably because your genes are spelled
wrong
right no
there aren't nearly enough genes to to
blueprint a body what there are
are
very simple rules that cause a body to
emerge in light of information that is
encountered in the physical universe and
the eyes are a prime candidate for this
sort of thing because
you know
your heads are different sizes you've
got two parents who may come from
different parts of the world what the
hell gene would you even write for that
you need a system in which two half
genomes can come together having come
from different environments with
different levels of close and distant
work and all of that and they can
produce an eye that works how do you do
that feedback at every level and at
every moment right and so one of the
places i would say we chronically
misunderstand biology is we tend to look
at the adult organism and we look at the
genome and we say oh the
genes say how you get there and then we
ignore the fact that there's this very
long process of development in which the
body gets to discover how it interacts
with the world and correct
all sorts of processes and the eye
nothing is more important than whether
you can see the important things in your
world the things relevant to your
fitness so the idea
that oh your eye is misshapen right oh
well you happen to have muscles that can
adjust the shape of the thing right
so
yeah the extrinsic eye muscles
are extraordinary and i mean even even
on a shark which is a remote
remote ancestor of ours to just to go
back to comparative anatomy space uh
it is
it is
obvious in retrospect
how much selection has built into
the ability
to not just move around but shape the
shape of
the eye orbit and the eye itself
absolutely absolutely and you know this
is this is an a you know a soft optic
right right it's all about the shape of
that thing and some very simple physics
and if you deny it information about
what it's actually seeing especially by
correcting it
the point is oh
these work great no they work great with
that thing in front of them yeah right
they don't work very well at all without
it
so
um
there's also lots in this piece that
goes to some other issues which are
places where we chronically
underestimate the complexity of the
systems that we are trying to understand
and ostensibly
fix one of them is in this article it is
described that there's this issue
where
part of the story that suggested that
you know the eyes are basically
becoming less functional because of
bad genes right a simple bad genes
argument has to do with uh heritability
right and the fact that you know uh
identical twins uh had
uh
worse
you know had eyesight that was more
closely correlated than fraternal twins
right which seems to you know in many
people's minds it just uh it locks up
the question you know permanently it
answers it
and now in this article they say
something along the lines of yes but you
know identical twins share more than
just genes they also share a lot of the
same influences right
and this is
a strange claim but it is
one of the things that dogs the claims
of heritability and their implications
about genes
is that
people leap from the idea that
the heritability of something and
heritability is defined as a genetic
term it is i think mistakenly but
formally defined as
the degree to which a
alteration in form is the result of a
genetic variant
this
ignores the mechanism by which these
variants have their implications right
so
you'll help me get this into clarity
that people will be able to understand
let's say that we had
i'm just going to describe the problem
with heritability even where we actually
measure correctly that it is there we
misunderstand the implications
can we pause for a second though uh can
you go back so you said this thing about
twins and i had missed that when my read
of the article and i just went and
looked at it
can i just read the paragraph here i
said i don't understand what they're
please what they're doing yep
this is again the
sentence from this article in myopia in
the atlantic this month
by now scientists have moved past the
faulty assumption that myopia is purely
genetic the idea took hold in the 60s
when studies of twins showed that
identical twins had more similar
patterns of myopia than fraternal ones
and persisted in the academic world for
decades
dna does indeed play a role in myopia
but the tricky factor here is that
identical twins don't just share the
same genes they're exposed to many of
the same environmental stimuli too
well i don't i don't understand
i don't understand how they that the
last phrase of the last sentence strikes
me as a totally bizarre place to end
that yeah it is it is a bizarre thing
and i think it's sort of a hand-waving
argument i don't know it must be what
they've elided is
uh identical twins raised apart or
it's not clear what they've missed but
they've missed a factor in there to
explain why they're they're making the
art
it would appear if you if you just read
this it would appear that they're
arguing that identical twins
share more environmental stimuli than do
fraternal twins so let me um
let me make my heritability argument and
then we're going to defend this bad
paragraph we're going to steal manna
okay okay
so let's take a totally separate
non-vision uh characteristic okay and
let's create a phony scenario in which
we're gonna see what's wrong with the
modern instantiation of heritability
let us say
that a population
of blue creatures has been enslaved by a
population of orange creatures okay
in the enslaving process the blue
creatures were portrayed as less
intelligent in order to justify the
hierarchy of power okay let's just say
it's nonsense but that was
uh
that's that's what orange was told
themselves that was the story the orange
creatures used to rationalize their
their enslavement
their enslavement of the blue creatures
and then let's say that time passes and
the blue creatures find their way to
freedom somehow and they now have to get
along with the orange creatures but the
story in the orange population persists
that the blue creatures are less capable
okay
now
what if you went and you
measured the degree of blueness
and some capacity like intelligence
right and you found that it was indeed a
bit lower
that's trouble
but
the problem is
you don't know why
the blue creatures
are exhibiting this feature
in other words it discrimination by the
orange creatures who have the power at
the point the blue creatures earn their
freedom
right is going to result in lots of
things being poorly distributed right
things that might be enriching in
childhood etc right so the point is you
might actually find a
heritability that is to say a genetic
factor that does predict something about
capacity but it may be that that factor
has nothing to say about how that
capacity comes to be what it does is it
you know if you found that you know blue
scales or whatever is on the surface of
these creatures was correlated with low
capacity it is entirely possible that
though genetically heritable it has
nothing to do with that gene describing
anything that creates capacity what that
thing does is it describes a pigment
that causes a creature be to be
discriminated against which results in
developmentally that characteristic
being less elaborated
does that make sense
so the point is
the blueness the thing that is actually
genetically heritable
uh may not be coupled at a genetically
heritable level with the capacity in
this case right it's like but the
phenotypic
the phenotypic thing that shows on the
outside can be recognized by others and
so can be used to basically you know
collect and uh and do something
collectively to those right and actually
let me let me take you to organisms one
step more absurd just to make it really
clear let's imagine that there was a
gene
uh for a sign
that would emerge on your back that says
kick me
okay that's all the gene does it just
produces this sign on your back that
says kick me
and that people listen to the sign
okay
now that sign that says kick me is going
to produce all kinds of other phenomena
right you're going to be fearful you're
going to constantly be up against walls
you're going to your behavior is going
to be altered by the fact that you've
been born with a sign that says kick me
on your back right
if fearfulness is actually an adaptive
response
but it itself is not genetically
heritable well no that's that's the
thing i'm trying to convey become it is
genetically heritable
it is genetically heritable the gene
that produces the kick me sign produces
fear
it does not produce fear by altering
your indirectly it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter from the point of view of
how we study heritability what we have
is this gene is
correlated with that phenotype
phenotypic characteristic
the mechanism is not specified and so
my point is heritability itself is a
broken concept in part because all sorts
of things that alter your phenotype in
one way or the other may indirectly
cause these things which are not
downstream of the gene itself but are
downstream of some characteristic that
it produces and we infer something
because of our overly simple genetic
model of the universe right but i i i i
think i think maybe you misheard me i
was very precise in saying it's
genetically heritable as opposed to
heritable which is
this is what i'm telling you if you go
to the literature
where the term heritability is used this
error is all over the place we assume
that genetically heritable means the
consequence of the spelling of the gene
that's not what it means
right it is a correlation that is
agnostic as with respect to mechanism
and so
this has
uh
lots of implications right for claims
that people make um
which we won't go into here but
nonetheless it is it is an error that is
extremely hazardous because it allows us
to rationalize things as well that's
features of the you know the underlying
genetic biology of the situation okay so
let's get there the point here is
to correctly say to correctly identify
oh that thing is heritable
is in no way to say that thing is
immutable right now with an individual
it might well be right but it is in no
way to say therefore you got it i'm
sorry your kids are doomed to have it as
well they're not right it is exactly
that issue that basically when people
get to the point of well it's
genetically heritable they believe that
what they have said is immutable and
they may have said nothing of the kind
right you may be able to completely
democratize something uh into uh
fairness
even though it was genetically
inheritable you may be able to remove it
from genetic heritability if it is not
the consequence of a genetic spelling
producing this thing as a matter
indifferent to the world outside okay so
now let's go back to steel manning that
paragraph
tank which i don't believe deserves
steel manning i think it's just an error
but um
nonetheless you could say i did a
paragraph the paragraph which is about
identical twins and which ends by saying
the tricky factor here is that identical
twins don't just share the same genes
they're exposed to many of the same
environmental stimuli too right now
here's the thing
identical twins look alike
okay so to the extent that they are
broadcasting signals into the world that
then cause the world to treat them in
such a way right they may cause similar
phenomena to emerge and it is
conceivable it is at least within the
realm of absurdum or however that's
pronounced uh with the don't kick me
yeah
if there's a
if you have a genetic tendency to
produce a don't kick me sign on you
uh if identical twins have some similar
thing
that they're producing in the world and
therefore getting the same feedback from
it there you go even if they haven't met
since they were born that is exactly it
that is exactly it
um okay so
okay
yeah i mean it's pretty good for
rescuing a paragraph that's pretty hard
to logically defend yeah
um okay i want to make several points
about this
myopia paper
one
a this is a classic case of hyper
novelty which did not i wanted to title
the section this section hyper novelty
is a [ __ ] hyper novelty is a [ __ ] okay
so this is a classic hyper novelty
problem and it has several of the
annoying characteristics of these things
right
one of them is
i am sad to say that although
i have been aware of the problem of us
having a hyper novelty issue with
development and vision we did not fully
protect our children from this it's
effectively impossible to do right zach
needs glasses and
the fact that zach needs glass really
though wow not to the extent that i knew
yeah he's not now i only wear them to
drive pretty much okay
and you're not right so i don't know
what degree people could hear that um
zach says now he only needs them to
drive
um can do everything else without and
you know i don't know what your diocter
is but you're like 20 40
which is which is really not that bad
which which just means that what someone
with perfectly normal vision uh can see
at 40 feet you need to be 20 feet away
from it to see it and i have the sense
that it may be getting better
it may well be getting better
someone someone with something like 2800
vision can't exactly get away with that
does it matter what you're driving at
that's a good you don't have to answer
that no it's not a very good point um
you're very good at calling me out when
i make it not a very good point
too frequently
yeah but here's the thing a i do think
you may find that it gets better
especially in light of the fact that
like all kids now
you had a lot of close in stuff put in
front of you before and your interests
are now more diverse in terms of the
distance that they are from you and that
may well provide the feedback and even
though it's late in your development it
may not be too late to partially or
maybe even fully correct and
unfortunately
driving i can't get away with it
right yeah you're damned if you do
damage you don't yeah
um but
my point is there are lots of these
problems where
the fact that you know about it provides
you some tool but it doesn't provide you
enough like you're now stuck as a modern
parent you're stuck with do i raise my
child in some way do i you know
freak out when they sit down to read
right because they may be damaging their
uh
feedback mechanism or do i accept that
reading has become dominant enough that
i should
that
allowing a certain amount of degradation
of distance vision is worthwhile right i
don't know what to do with that i didn't
know what to do with it you know in our
kids case i don't know what to do with
it i don't know what to recommend
but
here's the maddening place that the
article ends right the article makes the
exact
right connection without
uh linking to mike mu
it connects this failure of the eyes to
develop correctly because we've denied
them the proper feedback and it says the
same thing appears to have happened with
teeth
right oh my goodness yes it has the jaw
is misshaped because we are not chewing
on resistant enough stuff early enough
in development and then
it says
the absolutely stupidest thing it could
say can i just can i read it yeah so i'm
going to read the penultimate paragraph
too because i think that recovers the
article a little bit but then i'll read
the file okay
we may not know exactly how ogling
screens all day and spending so much
time indoors are affecting us or which
is doing more damage but we do know that
myopia is a clear consequence of living
at odds with our biology the
optometrists i spoke with all said they
try to push better vision habits such as
limiting screen time and playing outside
but this only goes so far today taking a
phone away from a teenager may be no
more practical than feeding a toddler a
raw hunter-gatherer diet
so this is where we've ended up oh
instantly
a raw hunter-gatherer diet yeah
hunter-gatherers were not eating raw
foods that's anyway
stop
so probably talking about
feeding them a raw hunter gatherer
so this is where we've ended up for
those of us who can afford it adding
chemicals and putting pieces of plastic
in our eyes every day in hopes of
tricking them back to their natural
state
so
i want then
it is the point before this where they
say they correctly say oh this is
analogous to what has happened with the
spread of the need for orthodontia right
true
and then they say
but it's marvelous because we know what
to do with orthodontia we put braces on
your teeth and
get them straight which is insane that
does not correct the misshapen jaw right
it is a terrible cluj put on top of an
unnecessary dysfunction that is actually
totally remediable if you understand it
from the get-go right so
yep there's also a there's a market
aspect to what is revealed by this
article
yes right there is enthusiasm about
braces because it doesn't make the
entire field of orthodontia go away it
makes it profitable
right if you understand why the why
malocclusion happens then you also
understand what is necessary to make it
a very rare phenomenon and if it's a
very rare phenomenon we won't need many
orthodontists will we right so no that
can't be the answer the answer has to be
we've got a modern problem and there's
nothing to do about it so what we have
to do is aggressively come in with
high-tech stuff and wizardry and fix
your children by putting tension on
their teeth which by the way will wreck
your
teeth's roots if it's done badly has
happened in my case
so
the problem is it's going to mess with
your skull it's probably going to mess
with your eyes
it mess well then and and the number of
pathologies that are downstream of
malocclusion is high because it's not
your teeth that are out of place it's
your jaws which are misshapen which has
effects on your breathing it has effects
on allergies it has effects on uh
attention deficit all sorts of things
are implicated
um and and interesting there are three
remedies in the piece for the eye
misshapenness
two of them correct the light coming
into it to give them a signal that
development can follow to fix the eye
which is
truly interesting right that's a great
it's the opposite of glasses which
correct your vision coming into the eye
so your eye doesn't know it's misshapen
right it distorts the uh
the light coming in so that your eye
will reform in the right way one of them
being drops that dilates your pupils
which apparently interesting little note
from the article is something that
cleopatra used to make her appear more
sultry yeah yeah i thought that was
pretty interesting too um but all right
i'm i'm
mostly at the end of
my rant this is both a marvelous article
in terms of what it reveals this is
finally dawning on people we are at
least 30 years late in the recognition
what we needed in order to understand
that we were doing this to our own
children
has been apparent for a very long time
we have been slow to get there and in
some sense i think the hidden message
here is we're only now getting there now
that we have some way to sell you a
solution rather than to prevent the
problem from happening yeah right and
that this has become
what the market does to all branches of
medicine including orthodontia dentistry
ophthalmology right it wants to sell you
a solution more than it wants to prevent
the problem from happening and it is a
terrible pathology for a medical system
to have
yeah and
there's so much analogy to the the
experience with covet as well uh wherein
this this was
uh a a monster of our own creation
and the people who worked hard to create
it are now trying to cover their tracks
and pretend it came from nature
and regardless of where it came from
we are told you absolutely need our
fixes to help you get fixed
and it's just the same story over and
over again yeah they uh it's they want
to portray themselves as the hero
rescuing us from
uh a terrible
villain from nature when in fact they
are the villain
and then they are the villain again and
selling you a remedy that has these
gigantic costs which they weren't honest
with us about yeah right and it's you
know it's like okay how many times are
we gonna fall for this
pseudo scientific garbage by the people
who are nominally our scientific leaders
when are we just going to start um you
know although still being fooled at this
point shame on you fool me once
shame on you fool me twice shame on
me so everyone who's still fooled
wake up wake up yep time to wake up
all right are we there i think we are
there okay
we're gonna take a break uh
get some more ducks in a v and
we will be back in 15 minutes or so with
a q a
there with the chat they'll be live on
odyssey again you can ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
you can always email logistical
questions like where do i ask questions
to darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com
um but just the logistical questions
uh there
and um please consider joining our
patreons again the question asking
period for the private q a that happens
the last sunday of the month is open
right now at my patreon
again if you are interested in these
kinds of conversations but especially
the conversation that we're just having
about myopia and hypernovelty and
how to behave in a way that
you are more likely to have a body and
brain in sync with one another and with
nature consider getting together's guide
the 21st century where we discuss this
and more
and
apropos
this week and always
be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside and
achieve greatness
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you